I was on a date, just about to eat dinner,
and I hear a growling sound.
And I look at the guy,
he says to me, "That's your
stomach, not mine."
(Laughs)
How do I not recognize the sounds
coming from my own body,
not to mention my own voice?
I love the sound of my voice
on a microphone,
but it didn't start out that way.
When I was younger,
I was in love with other people's voices.
And like so many of us,
the first time I ever heard
my voice on a recording,
I hated it.
I was 10 years old
when my mother bought me
a Panasonic cassette recorder
with a pack of Memorex
cassette tapes for Christmas.
See, singing on tape was my version
of bedroom musical play,
something that girls do
all around the world,
and it's really gendered.
Left alone with our devices,
alone in a room, girls play.
Singing, listening to music, dancing.
So with a gift in hand,
the very next morning,
the first thing I did was record my voice.
And when I played the tape back,
I was shocked.
It didn't sound anything like me.
There was a huge gap between
what I thought I sounded like
and what the tape was telling me.
And it was traumatic
because I didn't recognize me.
I think we all know that feeling.
But some of us are emancipated
from the doubt triggered by technology,
and some of us are not.
So I stuck to dancing in the mirror
and lip synching,
falling in love with other people's
voices instead of my own.
Now I am a digital ethnomusicologist.
I study Black tween girls,
particularly the unintended consequences
of their intimate bedroom musical play.
On today's mobile apps,
Black girls record and upload
the most viral dances on the internet.
But the songs that mute their voices
and sound pornographic
are overwhelmingly male.
For example, the song "Booty Hopscotch"
entices very young girls
to record themselves
while a male ventriloquist
grooms them to "Keep that ass jumpin',
Keep that ass jumpin'."
Girls say they don't listen
to the lyrics, but when asked,
they can sing every word
with no concern for the consequences.
Before YouTube,
before WorldstarHipHop,
the Black YouTube,
on the playground and in the bedroom,
the voices that Black girls heard
in their own musical play
were predominately their own.
But these days, online
Black girls are drowning
in the sounds of musical mansplaining
while bouncing ther booty
to the beats and rhymes of rap
that tops the Billboard
and YouTube charts.
Songs like, "Hands up, get low.
hands up, get low, hands up,"
tell them what to do and how to do it.
Curiously, the hook for that song
may have come, may have been appropriated
from a Black girls' hand-clapping
game called "Jig-a-low."
Jig-a-low is a contraction,
“jig” meaning to dance
and “a-low”, well, to get down.
"Jig-a-low, jig-jig-a-low,
I do my thing, yeah, on the video screen.
Yeah, well, my hands up high,
my feet down low.
And this the way we jig-a-low.
Hands up high, my feet down low.
And this the way we jig-a-low.”
Girls across the gender spectrum,
who love to twerk,
which is a culturally appropriate
and sophisticated style of dance
found throughout the African
and Afro-Latina diaspora,
are being enticed by sounds
that are produced,
engineered and written
90 percent of the time by men
who are enticing and taking advantage
of girls who love to dance
and treating them like adults
in their intimate bedroom musical play.
How do I know?
For seven years,
I've been studying a set of 650 bedrooms
twerking videos by Black girls.
They were uploaded to YouTube
between 2006 and 2014.
Over 1,000 girls from all around the world
selected 200 twerk songs
and only nine voices of women,
including Nicki Minaj, Beyoncé, Ciara
and one indie artist
named Katie Got Bandz.
So what's behind all this?
While girls are twerking,
feeling themselves, feeling empowered,
arguably the oldest technology
in our human evolution,
music, is taking over.
Beyond our conscious thought,
music lowers our threshold of pain
while it rewards us with the feeling
of social bonding and intimacy.
That's why we go to concerts,
that's why we crave that feeling
even when we're alone,
that's why music is self-soothing.
And it is.
It's a whole mood.
But that mood is grooming
younger and younger girls
to tolerate psychological violence
in dating situations
and in their own intimate
bedroom musical play.
Girls repeatedly do
what they're repeatedly exposed to.
Left to their own devices,
music as technology gives patriarchy
and anti-Blackness a head start.
Faced with doubt about my own
voice when I was ten,
the tendency to think
that the situation was about me,
about feeling insecure,
that was the tendency, not the situation.
The role technology plays gets lost.
Being best friends with my own voice
could have been my first
intimate relationship.
If very young girls were surrounded
by the voices of Black female voices,
chances are they'd assign
value to their own.
Bedroom musical play
could be the first time
a girl tunes in to her own
internal signals,
self-regulates it,
and learns to say "Yes!"
as well as, "Nope, not today."
But online, bedroom musical play,
like listening to your gut
or your stomach,
well, it's not a solo act.
Stereotypes and stigmas fed by algorithms
and audiences are silencing us.
But if Black girls produced
their own twerk songs
and preferred female musicians,
well, they could break the internet
in music and tech.
But that revolution in sound
can only begin
if they learn to like the voice
on their own Memorex tape.
Thank you.
(Applause)